los bomberos siguen trabajando a
contrarreloj en petrópolis para
encontrar a supervivientes tras las
fuertes lluvias de ayer que causaron al
menos 189 deslizamientos veintiuna
personas han sido rescatadas con vida
pero hay muchas denuncias de
desaparecidos el centro de petrópolis
parece un escenario de guerra hay mucha
destrucción cabe explicar que es una
localidad turística en la que muchos
cariocas pasan el verano porque huyen
del calor es una región serrana rodeada
de montañas y este es precisamente el
problema con las lluvias hay
deslizamientos todos los años solo que
la lluvia de ayer ha sido especialmente
fuerte en dos horas cayeron 260
milímetros de agua y peor la previsión
de hoy es de más lluvias aunque
moderadas por eso los equipos de
protección civil están en alerta cabe
destacar para terminar que no es la
primera vez que en esta región se
registra una tragedia medioambiental en
2011 hubo fuerte deslizamientos de
tierra en teresópolis en aquella ocasión
murieron
de 900 personas